the health secretary has said that kovid
could be with us forever and we have to
learn to live with it
javid compared the corolla virus to the
flu during the downing street news
conference yesterday saying we won't
shut down our entire country and put in
place lots of restrictions to deal with
it well as those restrictions begin to
ease there are understandably many
questions left to be asked about what
the coming months are going to look like
well here to answer some of the
questions that still remain we have an
expert panel this afternoon covering a
number of areas and they're going to be
impacted by these restrictions lifted we
have oxana paisak who is lead of the
outbreak educational programme in
infectious diseases at university
college london
sean simons founder of compton
investment agency we also have sue
hannah head teacher of litchfield
cathedral school and chair of the
society of heads and the features group
and stephanie dunn regional director for
the royal college of nursing in the
north west of england we have all bases
covered here on sky news this afternoon
welcome to you all i'll go to sean uh
who's ready to talk to us and it's a
return to the office today sean which is
good news for your sector as a
commercial property agent are we seeing
a rush back to the office or do you
think it's going to be a gradual return
well i think i mean it's not good for
our sector i think it's just i think
it's good for society and the economy
generally um i mean
quite frankly every city centre
relies on office workers you don't need
to kind of rent or sell offices like
myself to come to kind of to benefit
from it everyone will benefit from
office workers being back in the office
2021 was a very very stop start year um
people i mean with the government
messaging keep changing
people were threatened to come back but
it kind of never caught the momentum um
and last year obviously we started to
get momentum around october and then
omicron came and kind of killed all the
momentum we had all i can say is in the
first kind of two and a bit weeks of
this year
we're starting to see um
demand
dare i say get back to kind of where we
were pre-covered it does seem to be a
real appetite from
not only business owners but employees
to get back to the office um funnily
enough i think the longer this whole
process has gone on the more it
solidified people's views that they want
to be back in an office and i kind of
feel that the novelty that perhaps
started in in march 2020 has very much
now worn off yeah sean do this pandemic
this is the third call from the
government for people to return to the
office and business is hoping they'll
get a longer run at it now but it's
interesting you say about people wanting
to get back to the office because
anecdotally people have been saying look
the world of work has changed now people
are enjoying working from home
is that the case do you think going
forward is the world of work changes is
office space changing as a result
without question and actually the office
and the way the office behaved
pre-covered was was changing anyway i
think all that covert has done is
perhaps sped that up a bit hybrid
working is something that is going to be
a mainstay i believe in the market and i
think the way occupiers are looking at
the way their buildings look and behave
is definitely going to change
um i've been pretty unspoken since the
beginning of this
because when everything when this whole
thing started and ever said it was the
death of the office no one's ever going
to work i never quite believed it i
think the longer times gone on the more
that solidified you've only need to look
at kind of recent um some of the largest
businesses in the world kind of
committing to large sways of space
across the capital and across the uk to
kind of justify that but the answer is
yes it's changing
but they it needed to change um but the
office will live on
let's bring in oxana now oksana and from
a public health point of view the health
secretary said the lifting of
restrictions is a moment we can all be
proud of do you share that sentiment was
it the right thing to do because
statistics out today if you look at the
figures 93
of hospital beds are full this week 77
000 staff were off sick this week 46
covered related we talk about 100 000
infections plus per week and 83 000
patients going to hospital via ambulance
this week so when you look at the the
state of the nhs at the moment do you
think these restrictions are being taken
away too soon should it be more gradual
look we have more people now more than
double the people in hospital now than
when uh plan b was first implemented in
december so
um from a public health point of view a
tapered approach in um reducing
restrictions in a more tempered way in a
more gradual way
would be safer however i do agree that
return to work is an important aspect
but then we should also ensure that
those workplaces are safe we need to
have government regulated ventilation
standards uh as well as
if you're encouraging everyone to mingle
indoors again uh then face removing face
mask wearing isn't matching up with um
those calls for people to get back to
the office so from that perspective i
think you know the nhs is under
continued pressure however sacha javid's
declaration of good news seems to be
more of a distraction from partygate
than something that's grounded in data
and public health evidence stephanie
dumb when you look at the data are you
confident that plan a is the right way
forward at this time i reference those
figures there that you heard
absolutely not we're extremely concerned
as a college because our members are
telling us about those unsustainable
pressures that oxana has just referred
to
the data is telling us that the pressure
is there and it's mounting in many parts
of the system we have a situation where
we started we went into this pandemic
with 40 000 vacancies in for nursing um
and here we have i think as of the 16th
of january 29 and a half thousand staff
off sick
much of it being covert related huge
numbers of sickness happens absence
across the system
so
we're not seeing this lifting of
pressure we are seeing higher levels of
occupancy we are aware that social care
is under even more pressure or a similar
pressure around staffing and
availability of beds and capacity to
discharge patients um from hospital who
longer need to be there so
again i would echo the call for a more
cautious approach
we should at least be thinking about um
you know
some of those public health measures and
i think oksana is right
the the public health measures around
ventilation face coverings as people uh
return back to the office using more
public transport all of those things you
know
pose a big risk for us
i'm pleased to say sue hannah is back
with us head teacher at litchfield uh
cathedral school uh so we've
reestablished communications uh with you
it's good to talk to you i was just
saying that um one of the changes that
came in immediately was masks in school
so it's a case of here today literally
gone tomorrow and
did you welcome that move or was it too
much too soon in your opinion you didn't
really have much time to get your head
around it
no i have to say i absolutely welcome
that move and so did my students some of
whom are behind me working hard now
it's really incredibly difficult to
teach wearing a mask it's very difficult
for the children to learn wearing masks
they essentially don't like them and
whilst we completely understand that
you've got to balance out the health
risks
against those learning risks i think
there's also
a huge issue around mental health and
poor mental health and well-being with
young people and certainly the pandemic
has cast a really long shadow with that
the children have since they've been
back in school absolutely followed rules
around you know catch it bennett kill it
and
hands-face space and all of those kinds
of things can carry on
and i think we can continue you know by
our own risk assessments
in schools to behave with caution and be
sensible um and every school in every
setting will have its own risks and hot
spots to manage um but certainly there
was a lot of joy from our children at
the source of not having to wear their
masks anymore yeah i'm sure sue i'm sure
but what about parents because that's
perhaps the fly in the ointment of the
government's plan here in terms of some
schools will have outbreaks of covid and
say look we're going to have to go back
to mark wearing a lot of schools as you
said will be making their own risk
assessment but by the government lifting
restrictions so quickly
the school doesn't have any government
backup to the decision and we know what
parents can be like at school i'm one of
them and they will be very assertive
when it comes to the safety of their
children so the school will have very
little pushback do you think the
government being completely hands-free
is a bad idea in that respect
i think it does make things a little bit
more challenging for us there's no
question about that that you know but in
truth all along we've had to rely on
goodwill we've had to rely on people
doing the testing when they were
supposed to be doing the testing
and you know it wasn't being done in
school so
to some extent the responsibilities
around that have have stayed with the
parents and continue um to stay with the
parents i do understand also you know
the concerns of people and certainly
we've understood that all along there is
no doubt that we will continue to risk
assess and certainly as you rightly say
you know last term we had quite a
problem at the beginning of term with a
lot of staff and a lot of pupils out
with kovid
and we've brought in mask wearing before
the government said you should and
interestingly our parents were really
supportive of that it would be very
interesting to see how it works in
reverse though
and
see while we're on that subject we've
had a viewer um message us at lindsay
she said i feel very anxious about the
thought of self-isolation rules ending
it's possible that that will happen
towards the end of march and when i have
a vulnerable child who isn't able to
have a vaccination yet he attends a
school where the virus loves to spread
how can this be safe
they are the messages that are coming
into us at sky news and they're the kind
of messages you're going to have to deal
with a head teacher in the months ahead
yeah and i absolutely understand that
and we have a huge sympathy with
families that find themselves in that
position and certainly we've also got
you know pupils in school who've got
parents at home who are vulnerable and
they are also really concerned about i
have really scared children about their
parents
and i think that works in in both
directions too i think i would you know
just refer them back to the fact that
schools have been having to manage this
risk now for a considerable length of
time we've had to equip ourselves with
knowledge
and the ability to assess the risk
insofar as is possible and to mitigate
it and i have absolutely no doubt that
all schools across the country will
continue to do everything they can to
minimize the risk um to the children
that come in but the truth remains that
we cannot sanitize the world
um oksana the health secretary said we
are going to have to learn to live with
it he compared it to flu and it comes to
uh a question that adrian a viewer has
put to us he said it's highly likely
that kovid will stay with us like
seasonal flu and will it be a case of
annual booster jabs in your mind what
does learning to live with covid look
like
well uh that is a popular phrase and i
think sometimes it's used to cover up
lack of action um living with covet also
means that our schools are well
ventilated um and that we continue to
ensure that
we have access
to things like antiviral drugs for
people who are more vulnerable the
elderly etc
and in future it is likely because the
pharmaceutical companies are already
working on this
are tailored vaccines that are more
effective than the ones right now that
could work against a range of
coronavirus variants now that is
something that going forward would
really help to blunt
the impact of winter surges so hopefully
this is going to be
the last uh winter in which
more extreme measures would need to be
brought in but it's certainly not going
to be the only time that we're going to
see cases surge again even with um
layers of booster protection etc uh
however going forward we're going to
have more availability of antiviral
drugs plus potentially a type of vaccine
that's multivalent and is able to
recognize uh protect against
different strains and variants and
that's really something that um
would be available on a more of an
annual basis and what we are expecting
to hear in the next few minutes and news
on restrictions being lifted in northern
ireland before we get that i want to
squeeze in a couple more questions i'll
come to you um stephanie in terms of
self-isolation the health secretary has
said that that may come to an end uh
when the legislation is up towards the
end of march he said that will be
reviewed but in
but when the health secretary also spoke
yesterday he said that testing is key
and you do wonder what is the point of
testing is self-isolation is going to
come to an end do you think step
self-isolation should stay as government
guidance or as he compared it's a flu it
should be if you've got covid just use
your common sense and stay off work
yeah or work from home because not only
is he predicting the end of
self-isolation we're removing face masks
we're putting people back into
workplaces back into schools
some of them are overcrowded some of
them have got ventilation systems that
are not necessarily fit for purpose
because not all schools are equal and in
that environment the risk of spread is
enormous
so i think it's really important that
they do take a more cautious approach a
more phased approach to this because
we know that the nhs is probably at a
breaking point our nurses are really
struggling and they see
the i suppose the victims of some of
these these policies some of these
practices that lead people to be more
susceptible and more vulnerable and have
to be admitted to hospital but there's
also and i was recognizing the the
long-term impact and the mental health
impact of
the way we have had to live over these
last two years we are not really paying
sufficient attention to the impacts of
long covid how it affects people it's
affecting younger people it's affecting
older people and it's affecting the
workforce as well across all parts of
the economy so i do think until we're in
a situation where we've got
targeted vaccines we do need to
constantly think about
have we got
the right
protection measures in place are we
using them properly appropriately if we
are going to get rid of
self-isolation
do we need a rethink around
face masks and other other things yeah
stephanie you raise a really good point
then you raise a really good point there
in terms of the next step of what we're
going through we'll be
talking about long covid and its lasting
effects and of course mental health they
are the next steps um that as a country
we are going to have to go through um
final question to sean because we've
been talking about caution here but
people returning to work
put me in the picture about what this is
going to do not just for people working
in the office but local economies we
know the knock-on effect of um a
thriving office in a community we're
talking dry cleaners we're talking
sandwich shops you know we're talking
gyms
i mean i mean i think it's it's been
devastating i mean i my my offices um in
in farringdon um i've worked around here
for 18 19 years
um i've seen lots of people who i've i
mean barbers and
sandwich shops and convenience stores
kind of going out of business because as
i said you don't need to be an economist
to work out that if you don't have
workers office workers working in city
centres then the economics just don't
work um so i think this is going to be
a game changer quite frankly for the
last two years it's been a really
devastating outlook um and hopefully um
providing things are done in a safe and
measured way we can kind of keep this
momentum going um but i do anticipate
2022 is going to see a very large return
to of of the work force back into office
space and i think it's it's much needed
okay interesting to talk sean simons
oksana pisac sue hannam and stephanie
dunn thank you very much talking about
the easing of those plan b restrictions
return to plan a